sigue la guerra contra las pandillas en
el salvador ya van más de 100 días desde
que se implementó un régimen de
excepción las entidades estatales que
han reportado miles de detenciones han
cerrado el flujo de información oficial
aún cuando la legislación indica que los
datos estadísticos deben ser públicos y
este gobierno no ha sido transparente en
cuanto a datos pareció bastante difícil
que
y se logre acumular en las prisiones y
es el número de población a generar una
mayor crisis de la que hay ahora hasta
el 10 de julio el gobierno sitúa los
arrestos en más de 45 mil pero se
desconoce oficialmente el impacto que
han tenido en el sistema carcelario
salvadoreño
tampoco se sabe el número exacto de
detenciones arbitrarias que se han hecho
durante el régimen aunque las
organizaciones humanitarias registran
más de 3.000 denuncias de atropellos y
más de 50 personas podrían haber
fallecido bajo custodia estatal el
gobierno del presidente en allí buque le
dice haber derrotado a las pandillas sin
baño de sangre capturar criminales que
estuvieron que tuvieron de rodillas a
los gobiernos anteriores que tenían
secuestrada a las comunidades que tenían
armamento pesado que tenían estructuras
organizadas de forma casi militar que
tenían campamentos que tenían recursos
financieros armas pesadas y enfrentarlos
y están los derrotando así que hay un
baño de sangre es algo que merece ser
considerado por la comunidad
internacional las pandillas señaladas de
pepe la mayoría de asesinatos en el
salvador poseen unos 70 mil miembros en
el país centroamericano hasta antes de
una escalada de asesinatos y aprobación
del régimen las maras tenían a unos
16.000 de sus miembros encarcelados
según el presidente salvadoreño